et la map me disait tu n'as pas le
chapitre à la figure maternelle une
source d'inspiration pour flore lefebvre
des noëttes à la mort de sa mère il ya
quatre ans elle a pris la plume pour
raconter son histoire
c'est plutôt un hommage autour de tout
la figure merveilleuse de ma maman qui
était une espèce de mère courage les
années 60 et qui nous a élevés les
traits enfants étaient très à la maison
malgré un père qui était défaillant et
qui était qui était malade tout le temps
malgré la difficulté les difficultés la
maladie et cetera la cette famille
nombreuse c'est une vitalité
extraordinaire et donc c'est un hommage
à la vie
florent qu'après deux seuls les 30
personnages qui rythme la pièce ponctuée
d'une bande sonore typiquement années 60
pendant une heure la comédienne embarque
le spectateur au coeur de son enfance en
mêlant tragique unis
[Musique]
je force un peu le trait les caractères
de chaque personnage et comme le pat mon
papa était fou ça crée des choses assez
rigolote complètement décalé et puis la
natte donc la maman elle était aussi
très autoritaire cheftaine donc ça fait
plein de caractère très haut en couleur
et c'est vraiment commis quoi du début
jusqu'à la fin
avec une écriture teinté de proust ou
balzac au temps des trente glorieuses
les rires les peurs et l'énergie de la
meute de la matte prennent vie sur la
chaîne du prisme
[Musique]
là dans l'autre
ménages